are you nervous because you mentioned
earlier that you're starting to talk a
little bit more about politics about
being canceled or saying something that
maybe the the mob doesn't agree with so
so what is the mistake the mistake is on
the following the mistake is speaking in
certainties
certainties like for example alex jones
right now going through the issue that
he's going through right what is really
the problem what is the problem with
alex jones did alex jones say anything
that anybody else said no he's spoken
what i know for a fact this is what's
going on
i know it i'm telling you i have people
on the inside you can't talk like that
you can't talk like that's but that's
certainty that's a little too certain
where all you have to do is the
following
i don't know
what if it's this
maybe if it's this
maybe it's that i have no clue but what
if you are certain
there's a difference but there's there's
there's a difference he was not certain
though yeah so as long as you are
certain about something for example a
lot of people i agree a lot of people
can
make something out to be a certainty
even though but here's the part you're
certain about what though what are you
certain about what am i certain yeah
what are you certain about
five times five is 25. okay i'm certain
about that too 100 we're on the same
page what else are you certain about
the earth is spherical okay there's
certain things that we can be certain
about okay if you're certain about
something you don't have all the
information in it's a little foolish to
do that that's the part where you get
people to come you become a target you
caused it yeah i know for a fact marky
crash is happening versus like the other
day i did something with dave ramsey and
i said listen
dave don't know if you're watching this
or not i think you may be wrong
now he may be right with real estate if
inventory is not going to be there he
may be right but i think he may be wrong
and here's why
so then there's reaction videos and
people say what i disagree with david i
disagree with ramsay no problem but
until i didn't tell you 100
i said based on this data here's what
may be happening and you may want to do
your own due diligence people get in
trouble when they talk 100 percent
certainty here's what happened
and you don't know for fact so it's not
really a concern of yours at all zero no
because
because
it should be a concern of mine if i
talk from an area that i'm 100 certain
something is happening without me
knowing okay you have to be and you got
to work on that even as a talent you got
to be like let me back up a little bit
on this message up maybe because there's
been times that i've also said here's
what i think is going on and i'm pretty
confident this is going on but even
pretty confident is what
it's not certain it's not certain
so it's that one little out
that some of these guys got to put that
they're not putting in there
and that gets them in trouble so i'm
going to play this game and go do what
i'm doing because
i love it i can't stop talking about it
and i'm so totally fine when some people
pull me aside and say you disagree with
your position about that tell me why
which part of it i disagree with myself
sometimes but which part did you
disagree with when you set the following
this okay cool so what's your solution
tell me yours well i don't have one well
then don't debate it if you don't have a
soul i give you mind then give your
solution you're part of the problem as
well if you're not giving yourself i'm
giving you my solution what's yours
maybe you got a better one but until you
come up with your own solution don't
judge mine
give me a resolution that you got is
maybe better than mine now let's hash it
out let's debate it let's see if we can
find somewhere there so that's the part
also knowing how to
react to somebody that's confronting you
because the direction i'm going i'm
going to be confronted
and that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that if you
enjoyed this video i give a keynote a
few weeks ago in las vegas specifically
on the topic of cracking a code to
content creation if you've not seen it
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]